este es nuestro motor y aquí tenemos
nuestras baterías sabemos que si
intercambiamos las conexiones que vienen
de la batería podemos cambiar la
dirección en la que gira el motor pero
todo lo que podemos hacer con el motor
es ponerlo en cierta estructura y hacer
que se mueva y cambiar todo manualmente
lo que queremos hacer con base en
nuestras metas para este proyecto es
poder controlar el motor encenderlo y
apagarlo hacer que vaya hacia adelante o
hacia atrás cuando queramos lo que
hicimos fue elegir un microcontrolador
este en particular se llama arduino
pueden comprarlo en línea este en
particular me costó unos 20 dólares hay
versiones más baratas que pueden
conseguir en 10 ó 12 dólares y hay
versiones que pueden llegar a costar
hasta 70 u 80 dólares dependiendo de lo
que queramos hacer y cuánto trabajo
queramos realizar para ensamblar la
tarjeta
este viene pre ensamblado y listo para
usarse ya tiene la conexión para la
computadora por lo que es fácil de usar
y es por eso que elegí esta versión en
particular el arduino es un
microcontrolador de código abierto y
tiene su compilador que pueden descargar
escriben su código lo compilar lo suben
al arduino y pueden hacer que nuestro
robot se mueva y haga diferentes cosas
el arduino recibe datos de sensores y
usa de sus datos para decirle al robot
que hacer sabemos que tenemos un motor
que se mueve y sabemos que tenemos una
fuente de energía y también tenemos el
cerebro para hacer que se mueva pero hay
un problema no puedo conectar el motor
directamente en el arduino porque el
arduino no usa mucha energía eléctrica
usa menos energía eléctrica de la que
utiliza el motor por lo que el motor
quemaría a nuestro arduino así que
tenemos que encontrar una manera de
cambiar la energía alta del motor y
controlarla
y encenderla y apagarla de manera que
podemos controlar la dirección o
polaridad de la corriente sin afectar
directamente al arduino por lo que
necesitamos otro dispositivo para que
haga esto y este dispositivo se llama
controlador de el motor ya construir
este controlador de motor y veremos cómo
hacerlo es un controlador de motor solar
bo tics y vamos a hablar un poco más
sobre lo que hace que es controlar la
rapidez y dirección de nuestro motor
este cambia la energía alta de las
baterías y permite que fluya más
corriente y toma información de las
señales de nuestro arduino que es una
señal de baja corriente y bajo voltaje
así que esta baja corriente y bajo
voltaje llega a nuestro controlador del
motor y le dice oye enciende el motor y
muévelo en esta dirección y el
controlador del motor permite el paso de
corriente desde la batería a través de
el mismo controlador hasta el motor sin
dañar al arduino esto nos permite hacer
que funcione el motor con una mayor
energía de la que podríamos tener
hemos conectado el motor directamente en
el arduino la manera en que lo hace es
que la señal sale del arduino y llega a
estos pequeños puertos de aquí las
señales que llegan a estos puertos son
interpretadas por este circuito lógico
que es un circuito l 298 y este nos
permite controlar la energía que va de
las baterías hacia el motor aquí hay
otro circuito que es una fuente de
energía regulada de 5 volts esto nos
permite tomar 5 bots de las baterías
para encender al arduino por lo que
podemos sacar estos 5 bots desde este
bloque terminal y conectarlo al arduino
esto nos permite administrar diferentes
voltajes los motores van a requerir 12
volts de las baterías pero el arduino
sólo requiere 5 volts de esta fuente de
aquí
en la tarjeta tenemos estos diodos són
diodos de retorno que evitan que el
voltaje regrese del motor y dañe otras
partes del circuito cuando detenemos un
motor rápidamente o cuando revertimos la
dirección podemos tener un pulso de
electricidad que es regresa por la línea
y puede afectar otros elementos de la
tarjeta y ya que los diodos actúan como
válvulas que sólo permiten que la
electricidad fluya en una sola dirección
pues evitan esto y protegen nuestra
tarjeta aquí también tenemos unas
resistencias estas dos resistencias
tienen el propósito de proteger a los
leds de aquí estos leds son diodos que
emiten luz e indica la dirección de la
polaridad de la corriente lo que
indicará la dirección en la que gira el
motor y ese es su propósito y estos
receptores los protegen de recibir
demasiada energía y quemarse y aquí
tenemos un pequeño capacitor que es un
filtro que no permite pasar a altas
frecuencias
nos va a ayudar a suavizar las
variaciones de corriente aquí atrás
tenemos otras dos resistencias que
protegen varios aspectos de nuestra
tarjeta terminamos con estos dos bloques
terminales que es donde llega la energía
y el motor va a conectarse a uno de
estos bloques de esta forma y la energía
de la batería sale de ella y llega a
estos bloques terminales les mostraré
cómo ensamblar y cablear esto en el
siguiente vídeo veremos cómo se arma
esto y cómo funciona